hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today i'm gonna
be showing you the fastest checkmate
possible which is only two moves now
when i first started getting into chess
i understood how the pieces worked and i
understand basic concepts and i could
not understand how you could checkmate
in two moves because as I'm starting to
get material involved to the game that's
four moves right there that's twice as
many moves as I was told that someone
could checkmate so I was very curious
when I was in chess club in grade school
and our chess coach said see if he could
find checkmate in two moves after many
times looking at the board none of us
could figure it out and he said you
actually need to play as black to
checkmate in two moves and it ends up
looking like this there's a few
variations but white will need to start
with the mistake and that's going to be
moving his either G pawn or F pawn we'll
go through a few examples here and then
Black's gonna play could be six or a
five I recommend the e6 I'll talk about
why and then after the pawn moves to
either f3 or f4 then black comes down to
Queen h4 checkmate King can't go
anywhere the knight can't block it off
the bishop can't go anywhere this is
checkmate Black has only moved two times
now this is very different than if White
tried to do this because maybe we have
III and then same thing Black's gonna
make a mistake here with g5 but the
Queen just can't come to h5 it's not
checkmate so I this cannot be done as
white the fastest you could do it as
white would be with three moves but as
black you can actually checkmate your
opponent in two moves now one thing I
will point out is if your opponent play
something like g4 I recommend playing
east six now e5 is probably more correct
as far as proper strategy but you have
to give yourself a chance to do maton
two moves and if you play e5 this could
deter them from playing f4 they could
still play f3 but do you just give them
more options to play f4 if you play
something like e six because then they
could they're both now looking at f3 and
f4 as options if they don't you still
could have
very strong game you can just play d5
and play a normal style chest get your
dark strip is involved into the game all
that but you give yourself an
opportunity to checkmate in two moves
which is well worth the price of playing
this ecigs here so that is the fastest
mate possible other Asians they don't
have to play up here to f4 they could
just play f3 in this case only if they
play f3 what I say yeah II 5 makes a lot
of sense because now if they play g4
that you can play Queen down here if
they don't this is a terrible move in
general if they don't you still have
control of the center of the board so
that is how you mate in two moves again
they could play one of their G pawns
you're playing e6 they play this pawn up
here let's say 2 F 3 F 4 and then Queen
down here to h4 so if any our friends
asked how fast you can make your
opponent it's only 2 moves but remember
you have to do it as the black pieces so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
for those who are new to the channel
make sure you subscribe many of you have
probably seen this before but if you
haven't it's always fun to realize Wow
made into did not recognize I could do
that thanks for watching the video
and I'll see you guys next time
you